mesdames et messieurs bonsoir ce premier
dimanche du mois d'août a vu briller
l'été de tous ses feux personne ne s'en
plaindra je vous indique tout de suite
que demain la météo annonce également du
soleil et de la chaleur
au cours de ce journal nous parlerons du
problème des réfugiés avec la suite du
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux en
thaïlande du pétrole préoccupation
majeure de l'été de beaucoup de chefs
d'états de l'italie qui est un nouveau
gouvernement de la bolivie ou le retour
à la démocratie ne se fait pas sans mal
des vacances bien sûr du tiercé à
deauville et du tour de france à voile
mais pour commencer d'abord l'etna le
volcan sicilien s'est réveillée vous le
savez et voici ce que cela donne c'est
la plus forte éruption qui est connue et
n'a depuis plus de huit ans en quelques
heures 5 bouche c'est à dire des
fissures par lesquels jaillit la lave se
sont ouvertes dans les flancs du volcan
à 1600 mètres d'altitude
une coulée de lave haute de trois mètres
et large de 500 m à dévaler les pentes
de l'etna parcourant depuis hier plus de
8 km
ce son passage la coulée a détruit plus
de 50 hectares de cultures coupant la
route nationale en deux endroits
obligeant les habitants de deux petites
villes à fuir précipitamment et
provoquant la fermeture de l'aéroport
international de catane
pendant la journée on a craint le pire
allant jusqu'à envisager l'évacuation de
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
personnes dans les rues de catane par
une chaleur de 40 degrés les passants se
déplacer avec des parapluies pour se
protéger des cendres qui ont tout envahi
dans un rayon de 40 kilomètres autour du
vol
mais ce soir les volcanologues affiche
davantage d'optimisme car aucune
nouvelle bouche ne s'est ouverte et la
progression de la lahb semble se
ralentir
le problème des réfugiés du sud est
asiatique c'est un dossier douloureux
que nous essayons de traiter le plus à
fond possible
alors aujourd'hui nous y ajoutons un
document il a été filmé la nuit dernière
au large de la malaisie
voici ce qu'on appelle un boat people
c'est à dire une embarcation légère avec
à son bord des réfugiés désirant fuir le
vietnam le cambodge
ici un navire américain réussi à
recueillir les passagers de cette
embarcation
ce sont des vietnamiens ceux là auront
la chance d'être sauvé mais tant
d'autres périssent en mer ou attaqués
par des pirates
le ministre français des affaires
étrangères monsieur jean françois poncet
a reçu aujourd'hui pendant une heure
l'ambassadeur du vietnam en france
monsieur vendent sung pour évoquer
justement le problème des réfugiés du
sud est asiatique monsieur françois
poncet a rappelé que toutes les parties
doivent prendre les mesures décidées par
la conférence de genève en respectant
les droits fondamentaux des individus
vous savez que la france était l'un des
pays les plus intéressés qui s'est
inséré c'est lé plus vite à ce problème
des réfugiés
hier nous vous présentions le témoignage
d'un cambodgien installés dans un camp
thaïlandais à mes routes
il disait vouloir rejoindre notre pays
il existe quatre camps permanent
thaïlande et les envoyer dans spéciaux
d'antenne 2 ont visité donc celui de mes
routes
voici le reportage de jean claude de la
tramblais à mes routes
mahé rod l'un des quatre camps permanent
de cambodgiens réfugier en thaïlande
de l'autre côté de main et route c'est
le cambodge
dix sept mille réfugiés vivent ou plutôt
survivent dans ces camps certains sont
là depuis avril 75 date de l'arrivée des
khmers rouges au pouvoir 17000
privilégier si l'on peut dire puisque
recensés par les autorités thaïlandaises
est autorisé à séjourner dans le pays
jusqu'à ce qu'il trouve une terre
d'accueil
à condition bien entendu que cela se
fasse rapidement privilégié aussi par
rapport à 45000 de leurs frères refoulé
voici un mois et demi en territoire
cambodgien
quel sort leur at-on réservés combien
ont survécu que fuient le peuple
cambodgien le peuple cambodgien fait de
la famille le régime
le propre parce que comme vous savez
c'est un régime le plus bas du monde et
aussi ils fuient le ghana le bénin est
un pays ennemi héréditaire l'époque
maire et le but le vietnam est de faire
confédérés les pays anglo chinoise
comment sont les conditions de vie dans
quand nous avons de riz pour survivre
quant aux les vêtements nous n'avons pas
de l'argent pour acheter
et nous manquons aussi des médicaments
quand on est arrivés dans le camp on a
d'abord été un peu surpris parce que les
premières personnes qu'on a vu avait
plutôt l'air bien portante et ensuite on
est amis avoir pas mal d'enfants cachés
ctic très dénutri et pas mal de gens qui
souffrent et quand même de plusieurs
maladies surtout des diarrhées paludisme
maladie parasitaire diverses qui
entraîne une anémie certaines
tuberculose
mais ces maladies ne sont pas
spécifiques aux réfugiés elles sont
rencontrés dans tous les pays où s'est
développé où les conditions d'hygiène et
de nutrition ne fait pas favorable
il semble qu'il n'ait pas été vus par
les médecins depuis très longtemps et la
nourriture qu'ils reçoivent
il peut être pas tout à fait suffisante
du mois qualitativement suffisante
en effet l'un de ses sacs constitue la
ration d'une famille de 20 personnes
pendant trois jours la chatte ces
denrées alimentaires est financé par
l'organisation des nations unies et la
distribution est effectué par les
autorités thaïlandaises
mais l'hygiène alimentaire n'est pas le
seul souci des médecins sans frontières
les problèmes d'hygiène
à ce niveau là il y en a avancé et
prennent classique dans ce genre de
collectivités c'est le problème du
ramassage des ordures
le problème de des sanitaires des fosses
sceptiques et autres qui sont
complètement inexistante prennent des
puits qui sont vraisemblablement polluer
le problème spécifique de ce camp c'est
que la nappe phréatique se trouve à peu
près à 1 mètre en dessous du sol et donc
il ya des communications possibles entre
les endroits où les analyses et les
ordures ont été jusqu'à présent enterré
et cc puis il ya donc un énorme problème
d'hygiène à ce niveau là ils ont classe
père à court terme celle ce sont les
soins curatifs mais que
notre préoccupation importante ce serait
justement de les faire passer plus au
second plan pour essayer de développer
cet aspect d'hygiène à long terme
je suis sûre dans le camp ma femme et
mes deux enfants sont au cambodge
vous savez si elle est en vie non je ne
sais pas
pour ces hommes ces femmes ces enfants
le fait d'être en vie constitue déjà un
miracle car aucune famille n'a été
monsieur seniors par exemple que nous
venons d'entendre entamé sa fuite vers
la thaïlande
avec 10 de ses camarades deux seulement
ont franchi la frontière et sont
aujourd'hui dans un an tous ont souffert
tous ont vécu les atrocités perpétrées
par les khmers rouges
tous ont passé des mois des années
pendant lesquelles jour après jour vivre
constituer l'unique préoccupation
mais
oh
un thème de préoccupation commun à de
très nombreux pays c'est l'énergie en
france d'ailleurs le ministre de
l'industrie vient de dire qu'il fallait
construire rapidement des centrales
nucléaires dans l'ouest et le sud ouest
si on voulait éviter que se reproduise
une panne d'électricité comme celle du
19 décembre dernier il faut rééquilibrer
estimé monsieur giraud le système de
production transport de l'électricité de
france
notons également en matière d'énergie ce
que rapporte un journal du koweït ce
matin ils annoncent qu'une conférence
entre les pays arabes producteurs de
pétrole et les 9 du marché commun
pourrait avoir lieu le mois prochain
il s'agirait d'établir un accord à long
terme pour la livraison de pétrole à des
prix stables
ce serait évidemment une très bonne
chose aux états unis on le sait les
problèmes énergétiques sont l'une des
grandes préoccupations du président
carter dont la popularité auprès de
l'opinion baisse dangereusement le chef
de l'exécutif américain compte sur son
plan énergétique pour redorer son blason
son cheval de bataille ce sont les
supers profits des compagnies
pétrolières
jimmy carter dans sa lutte contre les
super profits espère avoir l'appui des
puissantes associations de consommateurs
dont l'efficacité aux états unis n'est
plus à démontrer je voudrais vous citer
quelques chiffres qui ont été publiés
avant-hier dans les journaux américains
et qui sont pour le moins étonnant il
s'agit des bénéfices des 24 compagnies
pétrolières américaines
pour le second trimestre de cette année
donc par rapport à 78 etc somme la plus
importante société pétrolière +23 %
la shell + 55 % texaco plus 132% getty
ioi plus 150 % et il y en a d'autres
à partir de ces chiffres le président
carter vient de demander aux américains
au peuple américain
sans doute avec l'arrière pensée de
faire monter sa cote de popularité qui
est maintenant tombé à -2 25%
le président carter viennent demander
aux américains de le soutenir dans la
bagarre qu'il lance contre ces 24
compagnies pétrolières américaines
et il n'est pas impossible qu'il
aboutisse à un résultat lorsque l'on
connaît la puissance des associations de
consommateurs aux états unis qui peuvent
se permettre par exemple de publier
presque chaque jour une page entière
dans les journaux américains
par exemple les américains on voit cette
carte de discrédit à leurs élus locaux à
la suite de x les gloro de défense des
consommateurs écrivent aux sénateurs et
aux députés pour demander de mener une
action contre les bénéfices des
compagnies pétrolières et le 17 octobre
sera organisé une manifestation de masse
à travers tous les états unis contre le
scandale des énormes profits des
compagnies pétrolières en proposant donc
de taxer les super bénéfices des 24
compagnies pétrolières le président
carter jouent le jeu des consommateurs
américains pour qui ces mêmes compagnies
sont bien les seuls bénéficiaires de la
crise certains vont même jusqu'à
suggérer de nationaliser ces compagnies
dans un pays où pourtant la libre
entreprise reste la seule règle du jeu
industriel et commercial
mais il faudra aussi que le sénat
approuve ce projet du président carter
ce qui ne semble pas évident le monde
politique étant de plus en plus hostile
à un président qui lui devient de moins
en moins populaire
sans oublier qu'il existe aux états unis
un lobby pétrolier sans doute aussi
puissant que le sont les 24 compagnies
pétrolières américaines
en iran la victoire des candidats
religieux favorable à l'ayatollah
khomeini aux élections de l'assemblée
constituante va sans aucun doute
accéléré l'islamisation du pays à
signaler et c'est un fait notable qu'une
femme a été élue elle a 48 ans mariée et
mère de trois enfants
c'est une spécialiste de l'enseignement
de la religion pour monsieur chapour
bakhtiar l'ancien premier ministre
iranien
une explosion est inévitable en iran il
affirmé aujourd'hui dans une interview à
notre confrère airtel en italie le
nouveau premier ministre francesco
cossiga suis fier d'avoir formé enfin
gouvernement a prêté serment aujourd'hui
au palais du quirinal devant le
président de la république sandro
pertini le cabinet formé par monsieur
cossiga composée surtout de démocrates
chrétiens comme lui n'apporte aucune
solution véritable la crise née en
janvier dernier en fait il faudra sans
doute reformer un gouvernement après
l'été c'est pourquoi les italiens
appellent celui de monsieur cossiga un
gouvernement balnéaire coup d'état dans
un pays d'afrique la guinée équatoriale
ancien territoire espagnol que l'on
appelait autrefois le río de oro
le président de la guinée équatoriale a
été renversé
par un putsch militaire monsieur n guema
le chef de l'état avait la particularité
d'être l'un des dictateurs les plus
sanguinaires du monde proche orient
attentat ce matin à jérusalem près de la
municipalité il y a deux blessés dont
l'un est dense et d'un homme dans un
état grave par dont la bombe était
dissimulée dans un tuyau en bolivie le
retour à la démocratie ne se fait pas
sans mal les militaires qui étaient au
pouvoir ont permis l'élection d'un chef
d'état civil mais les partis politiques
chargé de choisir le président n'arrive
pas à se mettre d'accord
la situation est bloquée la raison de la
crise c'est que nuit hernan ci laisse le
leader de la gauche ni victor paz
estensorro le candidat de la droite qui
n'ont pu obtenir la majorité absolue aux
élections
je sais s'il est fort de ses 15 cents
voix d' avance dans le vote populaire a
même été jusqu'à entamer une grève de la
faim pour obtenir la paix zoug ne sais
pas et 500 euros lui a obtenu plus de
sièges au parlement et donc il estime
que la victoire lui revient de tous les
scrutins se succèdent au parlement et
chacun restant sur ses positions
la passe est pop quant à l'ambiance des
débats et les fiévreuses regarder plus
les militaires qui avaient organisé ces
élections pour rendre le pouvoir aux
civils sont choqués par ce qu'ils
appellent le cirque parlementaire ils
ont lancé un ultimatum aux députés
élyséen président demain au plus tard
ont ils dit où nous reprendrons le
pouvoir alors que la fièvre gagne les
supporteurs de descamps venus manifester
devant le parlement
madame rosalynn carter qui devait
arriver demain pour assister à
l'investiture du nouveau président a dû
annuler son voyage il y aura un an
demain le pape paul 6 décès de jean paul
ii a évoqué en ce dimanche son
prédécesseur il semble a dit le saint
père que son plus ardent désir apple si
cet été de pouvoir servir jusqu'à la fin
et de s'en aller au moment opportun sans
déranger personne
le vatican publie un texte inédit du
papil 6 écrit en 1972 et dans lequel le
pape disparu évoqué sa propre mort qu'il
considérait comme une solution
providentielle pour l'église demain nos
différents journaux antenne de 12h et
20h évoqueront le premier anniversaire
de la mort de paul 6 vous pourrez
entendre notamment une interview de jean
paul ii à nos envoyés spéciaux rubrique
vacances suite parlons pour une fois des
français qui vont loin par exemple les
états unis où nos compatriotes sont de
plus en plus attirés sans doute aidé par
les prix avantageux des charters
l'équipe de dennis blair a retrouvé
plusieurs français en louisiane
voici comment ils passent leurs vacances
quand on est français imbibé dès son
enfance par le négoce spiritual il
arrive bien un jour pendant les vacances
qu'au détour d'un chapter on parte pour
la nouvelle en l'air
hélas résonne encore la trompette de
louis armstrong et les complaintes de
mahalia jackson avec en prime et c'est
pour ça qu'on est venu l'embouchure du
mississippi
prenez partie des us pour les usa
surtout pour le côté musique
d'intéresser le plus
or la première usine à petit tout ce qui
est beau grâce musique cajun
jazz blues ce mois ci en rial et ont
annoncé des prix très abordables
sa photo de 2,3 dollars le tout
seulement préparer ses vacances c'est
aussi un métier plus on va loin plus il
faut prévoir et se renseigner ce n'est
pas parce que la nouvelle orléans a été
fondée par les français en 10 718 que
l'on peut y camper comme sur le bassin
d'arcachon pour faire des économies
45 degrés sous la tente c'est trop ici
même les chevaux portent des chapeaux
c'est dire nous avons essayé de faire du
camping la chose que nous avions oublié
c'est que
la louisiane jour au niveau des
tropiques est campé dans une canadienne
de place sous les tropiques
c'est très difficile donc il a été
obligé d'abandonner la formule du
camping et se rabat en ce moment là sur
un autel et là les prévisions
financières s'écroule un seul moyen de
s'en sortir le hamburger et c'est dur
après trois semaines pour le france est
écrit alors cette cuisine américaine au
bout de trois semaines comment po
mais le plus difficile c'est peut-être
de communiquer si l'on n'a pas étudié un
peu que son tailleur et riche que sa
sister is not a boy
on passe à côté du piment qui commençait
révèle le goût d'un riz qui ne colle
jamais d'un oncle aux cheveux blancs
lors des situations cocasses qui vous
sont arrivés dans les sports américains
vous voulez rencontrer trois bulletins
de poèmes de langue quoi encore quelque
chose d'autre chose
je sais pas comment des trucs comme un
salut du poulet ou
mais l'important n'est pas de gagner
mais peut-être d'y être allé car raconté
c'est aussi des vacances
vacances encore en évoquant cette fois
un drame
trois personnes sont mortes noyées tout
à l'heure dans la baie du mont saint
michel et deux autres ont pu être sauvés
il semble que les nageurs étaient
surpris par la marée montante devant la
plage de dragées j'ai deux rendez vous à
vous proposer sur vos petits écrans
demain à 21h30 jean pierre elkabbach et
louis blériot dans leur émission
question de temps vous présentons le
dernier reportage de la série qu'elle
france
une série qui a connu un très grand
succès et vous le savez qui présente les
régions françaises vues à travers leurs
habitants demain donc la gironde dans
question de temps à 21h30
et puis autre rendez-vous antenne de
midi sera transmis du haras du pin voilà
qui va intéresser les amateurs de
chevaux que j'habite à rester attentifs
puisque nous en arrivons au tiercé qui
se courait aujourd'hui à deauville il se
courait dans le prix du casino de
trouville et vous voyez l'arrivée
bientôt dans la dans l'ordre ne verrez
donc le 304 dont scarlatti je vous dis
al avance puisque vous savez de toute
façon déjà les 306 apostolat les 307 des
das pop 307 était le grand favori après
photographie pour départager le deuxième
et troisième la combinaison gagnante est
donc le 4 le 6 et le 7 dans l'ordre il
rapporte 6120 francs et dans un ordre
différent
1224 30 pour 5 francs bonne entente 4 6
sec
le tour de france à voile maintenant
suite du carnet de bord dans régaler
nous arrivons à l'étape la rochelle
royan et à la fin de la première partie
de la course
les bateaux vont être démâté afin de
passer de l'atlantique à la méditerranée
non
royan les voiliers du tour de france ont
quitté leurs éléments pour une étape un
peu moins glorieuse que les autres cap
sur port barcarès en méditerranée en
effet à l'embouchure de la gironde les
25 bateaux ont été démâté et chargés sur
des camions
les routiers ont remplacé les skippers
et leurs équipages qui prendront ainsi
quelques jours de repos avant de
repartir jeudi de port barcarès jusqu'à
la grande motte première étape en
méditerranée
l'année dernière les 25 voiliers étaient
passés d'atlantique qu'en méditerranée
par le canal du midi
cette année les bateaux sont plus grands
et leur tirant d'eau c'est à dire la
longueur de leurs qui ne permet pas de
renouveler cette opération
on pourrait bien sûr envisager un
passage par gibraltar mais il faudrait
au moins une dizaine de jours dans les
meilleures conditions avec bernard decré
l'organisateur du tour de france à la
voile à un premier bilan à mi course
d'avoir une surprise
je ne pensais pas que le niveau serait
aussi haut aussi rapide langues
je m'explique que c'est quand on voit
avec du est une grande gentillesse des
grands noms comme pajot comme riddle
comme florence arthaud
gilles le baud qui viennent pour une
course qui avait dès la première année
un bon succès mais on se disait c'est
gentil quand ils viennent courir sur nos
bateaux sont les bateaux monotypes et
qui ont qu'ils ont la simplicité de vie
écoutez il ya un sacré niveau et qui
finissent 4e pour le meilleur 12e 10e
est différent mais ça signifie quelque
chose se produire du tout sont de
mauvais marin son éclairement mais je
crois que là on part à mme segal ça se
bagarre le 24e est excellent sincèrement
depuis le départ de dunkerque le 16
juillet les 25-30 ont parcouru près de
15 cents kilomètres sur les côtes
françaises de la mer du nord à
l'atlantique une heure et quinze minutes
séparent le spi jaune leader de la
course brest du second marseille
mais cette épreuve n'est pas encore
gagnée pour les bretons en effet si les
courants et les marées pour ce peu de
problèmes sur les côtes méridionales le
vent par conti et capricieux et ne se
trouve pas forcément là où on va le
chercher
il faudra donc attendre le 19 août avec
l'arrivée à menton pour connaître le
vainqueur cette année du deuxième tour
de france à la voile
voilà bien les concurrents eux mêmes des
maths et vont pouvoir se promener
tranquillement parce que la météo de
lundi prévoit du beau temps avec des
températures estivales sur la plus
grande partie du pays quelques orages
éclateront sur les alpes du sud et la
corse
des nuages reviendront sur les côtes de
la manche provoquant de faibles plus
pour terminer un autre genre de course
tout à fait original celui là puisqu'il
s'agit d'une course à faire rêver sur la
ligne de départ on ne trouve que des
rolls royce une façon comme une autre de
passer ses vacances
permettez moi de vous présenter tout
d'abord une des vedettes de cette
journée la voix grauls du défunt roi
olav de norvège
le fait que celle que le roi de halle
est intenté au repas tin oo avait gagné
au parc est celle de la reine
d'angleterre retenu par des obligations
antérieures ne se refuse pas présenté au
départ n'affectait pas excessivement la
qualité intrinsèque de ce défilé
car sous l'angle strict de la plastique
la rolls quelle qu'elle soit demeure la
plus belle voiture du monde ainsi que
chacun le sait depuis le début de ce
siècle
même si pour la plupart des hommes
son usage se réduit la trouver la
solution d'un problème de robin est une
genre étant donné qu'une rolls consomme
en moyenne 30 litres au cent que vingt
quatre voitures discuter ce rallye sur
les 230 km du parcours paris kaboul
trouver un accès durable
reste que c'est la voiture c'est voler
une voiture avec laquelle vous pouvez
rouler sans assez drôle sans vraiment la
paye et sert que vous achetez une rolls
vous la gardez au bout d'un bon bout de
temps voulait revendre et le même pré
coulerait faye et même plus si vous
l'avez garder longtemps qu'il est très
bien entretenu
cela dit si l'on veut bien considérer
que chaque rolls faite entièrement à la
main n'est pas seulement même d'occasion
ainsi extérieurs de richesse mais aussi
quelques tables oeuvres d'art les quatre
mille amateurs de l'enthousiaste clubs
répartis de part le monde sont loin
d'être tous des nababs pas mal d'entre
eux considèrent en effet qu'en tant que
l'oeuvre d'art la rolls peut-être d'un
usage plus pratique que la vénus de milo
du moins si l'on doit se déplacer tant
soit peu
c'est peut-être ce qu henry royce
le constructeur que rob aurait à sa
manière lorsqu'un confrère qui lui
demandait mais quel est votre client le
plus célèbre
ils répondaient tous mes clients sont
célèbres
voilà bernard pradines haut que j'ai vu
arriver tout à l'heure en vélomoteur
sera à votre rendez-vous de 23h30 pour
le dernier journal avec tous ceux qui
ont préparé cette édition je vous
souhaite de passer une très bonne soirée
à